citizens of the reject Nation I am so
happy you clicked on this video today
because we're gonna watch Andor episode
seven John how goes it uh it goes It
goes well sir how goes you the force
goes well within Greg today Force ghost
thank you so much for being here leave a
like first order of business second
order first order get it second order
thank you to all who have uh joined us
on our patreon page because uh your
support means the world to catch a full
and threat to watch along is there third
order of business thank you to Tops for
sponsoring this video and introducing us
to Star Wars card Trader so excited to
be working with them because as you
nerds uh like uh no we would love to
collect we all love to collect stuff
there's a lot of ways to collect the
things you love and the way Star Wars
car trader works is it lets you collect
your favorite Star Wars characters
weapons spacecraft more John this is
when you should be showing your phone
dude look you got me a storm
so you can admire it at your collection
from anywhere anytime and then so they
have keep keep the phone up because this
is a real cool thing a phase they have a
ton of exclusive collectible content to
discover plus you can meet and trade
with other Star Wars fans across the
Galaxy anywhere anytime to help complete
sets and missions earn Awards and more
plus you can even take the cards you've
already gotten combine them make new and
even more rare collectibles on the
workbench it's a great Star Wars
positive community experiences which is
something we heavily encourage so guys
this app is free to play on IOS and
Android so join us now on Star Wars car
trader by tops Link in description
right back to staring out that window
what makes you believe the Bureau of
Standards is in the market for
individuals
that's brown suit it's your interview
perhaps you would like to come along I
know people don't like to hear this but
this looks very Star Trek blasphemy what
is it that you hear my caller saying
look at me I don't believe in myself I
am desperate for approval
I wonder from a whom the use of any
local custom Festival is cover for Rebel
activity
will trigger permanent revocation of
Imperial tolerance I spoke with Emperor
Palpatine last night Palpatine name drop
any criminal act
with even indirect effect on the Empire
well henceforth be branded are class one
offense
straight into their hands
whose hands the rebels they should
listen to her what would you call it
announcement yeah she's right she's
right a surgical strike I
tracking devices in the Escape Route
disabled prior to increasing hyperspace
134 ounces
splurges an awful lot of money on these
artifacts that's all she does
your everything seemed to be all about
bringing in the Savior to access your
family funds
I've warned you where we started you
told me we were building a network what
were my words this song something else
entirely you knew where this was going
you've always known yeah
so good at that you realize what you
said in motion it was time for that as
well poverty won't hesitate now exactly
time has come to force their hand people
who suffer
that's the plan
you're not angry at me
I'm just saying out loud what you
already know
you're angry at yourself you spend so
much time planning but not taking action
take that action people think we're
kidding when we say it but it's true
there are no small jobs that the Bureau
of standards clearly top 20 lifetime
employee
you'll be surprised
for sure Maulana won
oh there's a rebel murder of running
tree because of corruption and laxity in
the corporate Authority I was punished
for trying to uphold the law can you
validate me please I fully intend to
clear my name and have my record
expunged why don't we start that process
now
probably best for everyone to just edit
this a bit before signing you in but I
don't agree with the moral conscience of
that leave it all make it as difficult
for me as possible
I love that you get so much of what
actual life is like day to day
oh she got back
[Music]
holy [ __ ] good
yes
that would be the most horrifying thing
to see in person surprised it took her
that long I noticed the ship
we have a loose end Cassian Andor who
you know is Clem
you need to find him
find him and kill him we can't have him
walking around with Lucian in his head
oh God you mean kill him this is what
Revolution looks like well dirty
business we'll send you what we have on
him
does Lutheran order that I feel like
Luther's gonna want to retrieve his uh
kyber piece yeah I hear you
just hold on
oh he missed him so much I want one
fingers to the Troopers now oh buddy
picked out Primo took over the hotel
ferrics is under Imperial Authority
so thank you Cassie
oh come on
common we won't have to worry about that
we're getting out of here
we're leaving
tonight go where anywhere we want
I got lucky or ahead or when did you do
we go we go tonight tonight
yeah why not oh no
get out of the cold I'm done find
somewhere warm and easy she's so gonna
die
thank you
just give me a couple more minutes
what's wrong
I'm here what are you not telling him no
I get so tired what are you not telling
him
I'll check up on Biggs and we'll pull
out first thing in the morning
all right so the first thing
don't leave her Americans do you always
seem to be away when I'm there I'm not
that hard to find one not for a senator
you're right I've been a poor friend no
that's not what I meant someone's gonna
kill me soon we're both a long way from
where we started
somebody changed so much
we've all had to adapt
is it that bad everyone's always passing
some kind of judgment on her huh
Can I
call back our old kinship
oh I
won only three people in the Galaxy know
about and I'm hoping I can trust you
is this personal or political you
haven't seen this guy in a while man
political then I'd suggest you hesitate
why there's a lot of [ __ ] people
around yeah your world is inescaping
relings to the Empire you're with these
people all the time
I'm not sure you're aware how far it
feels some of us have taken our
political allegiances these days You're
Just casting your vote for the best
person to tell her secret to keep
smiling
for having a happy chat about Childhood
Days
I'm not sure I understand
no
we don't
you gotta play along a little bit man
you are the most conspicuous person in
the room clear picture isn't it I'm a
polite sometimes indecisive Senator
who's been today is fighting and failing
to protect separatist do-gooders right
with her husband yeah the mon mothma
people think they know
it's alive it's a projection it's a
front
smile
this guy I know they want me and I want
that
and thinks I'm an irritation
there's a good chance they'll Miss what
I'm really doing oh you badass raising
money
yeah
performing a shadow and charitable
outreach program I'll ask you to be
chairman it will involve visits here to
Coruscant
alternatives
you're my best child you haven't
answered my question and I went you're
better off not knowing
or perhaps you find my politics a bit
strong for your taste
do it right here on the couch and your
politics are so freaking hot may I steal
her back there's a few guests that
require special handling of course
to be continued
I don't know what that [ __ ] was talking
about
what did I just agree to what are my
politics it's not safe here
Tim
I guess he thought you and I were back
together did have a love relationship
what happened to you
I ran into a wall like I do
but the entire town at risk and all
those Imperials on the street if demon
kept his mouth shut if this if that we
were doing a little user scam you borrow
you lie you disappear your crazy
boyfriend tries to get me killed and I'm
the villain you need to get as far away
from here as you can
this is not how we expected this to go
you won't have to worry about me anymore
you're worried about you now I need to
know about the other guy you ever talk
to him again tell him I held up my end
of the deal
and he needs to forget about me that is
the last time they're done and that goes
for everybody tell everyone you saw me
tonight of what I said here today
you too
come on go with them
grieving man
you're gonna bump into some freaking
Imperials
oh and he's clean shaven again sort of
that's not good
this is not our podcast oh wow didn't
think we'd be going here
stay here
on now you're only making things
they're gonna hit their targets today
clone troopers
those are stormtroopers
he's put it back
I'm not going
what are you talking about I'm staying
but it's it's not safe
I know all that can't run from this
what's left to keep you here the
Rebellion
what
fairix has been hiding long enough for
13 years every time I walk down Rick's
Road I turn off before I get to the
square I take the long way around so I
don't have to think about Clem hanging
there
oh
oh he took on the name Clem attack it oh
Donnie have you heard about this yeah
though
yeah
I put on my best coat and I walked
across the square with a smile on my
face oh my God you inspired
there are heroes brave enough
a whole Imperial Garrison I'm brave
enough just to get out here
I don't expect you to understand
not at all the irony I've been lying
around waiting to die long enough
the Marvel not
I run away
heartbreaking
the money you found and go and find some
peace I'll be worried about you all the
time
This Love
nothing you can do about that travels
across space and time never loved
anything the way I love you
and I've never fretted
on anything more but this time
you can't stay and I can't go that's
heartbreaking
can I speak now
let him speak tell me you understand I
don't
you will you
use damn he took on the name Clem and
Clem took a stand you're gonna have to
do a lot more living up to that name
good news I'm afraid not
I wish the lodger charge against the
fellow supervisor
oh man I believe our sector protocols as
described in the ISB code of conduct it
risks compromising Imperial safety to a
degree that silence is no longer
possible use this guy supervisor mirror
do you mind having your integrity
ventilated in public
I use the Imperial emergency act in the
wake of aldani to gather data across
multiple sectors without official
sanction but that is the wrong question
do you really think the rebels care
about the lines we draw on maps you
think the relevance of my work has been
supplanted systems either change or die
this guy's just reacting so much there
is a focused organized Rebel effort to
acquire highly restricted Imperial
military components I can now prove a
link between the theft of our most
secret equipment and its distribution to
Rebel groups across the Galaxy it's
weird that I wrote her I know right
like you go wait a minute
I'm wondering where we'd be right now if
everyone here showed the same Endeavor
as supervisor mirror we need more of
that around here spunk spunk spunk you
got Moxie kid I'm reassigning the
Maulana sector to supervise a mirror
ferrics is of great interest to her and
has clearly become a distraction for you
supervisor Grande you will accelerate
your schedule young I will expect your
report on Old Mandel tomorrow aren't you
glad you addressed this
Miami
I need another pass in this visual
effects there
did I look guys let's get some clouds in
here maybe make it darker
the cave
dude I'll keep up the beach he'll be
open
I was planning to go the other way the
second vaguely sexual situation in all
of Star Wars
so many sense memories
[Music]
there goes Aladdin
don't don't act suspicious
huh playing that game with the monsters
you keep looking around just trying to
figure out what's going on you're a part
of it part of what
Play Down racist cops sure Trooper why
would I be running because you're a part
of it
what
I'm here if you want
the rest of yours what you heard me wait
no hey okay unit tourists don't run but
I'm not running you got that right
great reveal shot I'm just going through
the stories right there you need to calm
down sir God damn this guy hang on to
this one for me I want to check the
shelter
everything
watch
charges
walking an Unleashed massive animal
fouling
wow what a crock of [ __ ] yeah civil
disruption anti-imperial speech fleeing
the scene of anti-imperial activity when
I'm just a tourist apologies all round
then
six years Jesus
wait I'm just a tourist wait
wow what a Croc
that is definitely not a commentary on
anything guys
the thing
in our lives today that would reflect
that
[Music]
damn it Cyril just do your job
this is a funny note to end on Kick It
Off John this was quite uh an
interesting episode you know after what
came previously obviously you know you
have a big Crescendo and then we're
gonna have to do some resetting of the
place and see where the aftermath Falls
so you know I mean this might not be my
favorite episode of the Season thus far
but it's maintained a certain level of
consistency even through this just
seeing yeah I mean I liked the increased
sort of look now that we get at what's
going on with Mon mothma and even to an
extent her involvement with Lutheran and
just everything kind of surrounding her
position now getting a little bit more
fleshed out seeming like she's gonna
take more of a focal position in the
story now moving forward now that the
Rebellion is sparked off and now that
her position is going to become even
more
uh you know heavily scrutinized and you
know it's gonna make for a lot of
tension I would imagine moving forward
for her because of all those things she
keeps describing as these annoyances to
the Empire that she you know is funding
as a means of distraction toward them
and uh I appreciated just that as as
awkward as her friend is throughout that
whole scene I appreciated just the
establishment of that idea and getting a
better sense for her strategy overall
not just where her morality is
um so yeah getting her uh is sort of
more heavily featured and then cutting
back across I think it's funny this
focus on her and then also focus on uh
what is her name Miro uh in the Imperial
Circle there you know sort of working
her way up and and like you said that
weird sensation where you're like you
are rooting for her in her isolated
story but not so much you know actually
in the overall situation
um so yeah I thought it was an
interesting blend of flavors and then
you know you get a a bit of the
desperation uh in the aftermathon
Cassian side and waiting still to see
when he takes up you know some kind of
real mantle of belief but uh but yeah so
far continuing in a in a conscientious
way I think what'd you think of his
arrest scene and how that all went down
I mean that was interesting surely I
mean definitely is ripped out of today's
uh you know it's a good example of the
kind of hassle somebody gets when yeah
somebody with power and authority you
know can kind of Judge for themselves
without any other sort of protocol
really holding them back and yeah I mean
I feel I feel like a lot of people
watching that sequence would probably
have some some harsh memories or or some
harsh connotations because yeah it's a
very real thing that happens to people
and and the more it because he is so
benign the entire time you know it is is
completely maddening because though we
know what's going on with him we know he
is you know a fugitive and yet at the
same time in that moment he really is
doing nothing wrong he's not doing
anything very suspicious he's trying to
find out where those other people are
going but they're not even really at
least in the way it's portrayed to us
they're not even really close together
it doesn't really look like they're
together
um so yeah it seems like a completely
frivolous and messed up
harassment by Authority for him
that is true that's very true
yeah I thought that was was it the right
answer yeah there's anything right uh I
thought that it was interesting going to
that beach sequence it felt very I'm
quite I can't quite find the the words
for uh what it was that they did
differently about this episode it's a
heavy debate episode and there's a lot
of fierce strictness all over it which I
I think is great I I like this episode a
lot I thought it was really really solid
and the way they're building up mon
mothma especially like that when she's a
guy I forget that guy's name is it here
on the menu right now do we see it coma
her friend Colma Tay Tay coma Tay coma
yeah there it is uh with takeoma
that scene that she had with him you
know it's
it is interesting where at the beginning
of this she's confronting Lutheran about
the position that he took and the charge
that he took the initiative
and how distraught she is over it and
fear of what might come but Lutheran's
just there to remind her that
you knew this was going to happen and
I'm just telling you what you already
knew
and then in her own family setting her
own Inner Circle immediate setting worse
than whatever like her and Luther were
doing like she is conducting this
conversation literally inside and just a
few feet away everyone she's gonna have
to put she's putting up this guy's
towards and she can't tell this uh take
home a guy the truth and she has taken
on the position of like Lutheran a lot
in that particular scene
and uh even with her saying like you
can't I can't trust my husband like she
stays in the marriage as part of the
facade as part of the cover in a way you
know I don't know what divorce is like
in Star Wars world I don't know I've
never seen a character go through a
legal battle yet but it sounds like
um like I I love this is my favorite
episode of hers by far like I think what
they explore about mon Mothman here
getting a little bit dirty as well
um that was great you know not getting
dirty but having to play the the
undercover game in a realm where it's
not about talking with Lutheran who's
orchestrating a lot like she's having to
try to maneuver a conversation here in
her favor to get some credits to get
some money
and I just thought was uh like a
fascinating game of tense tension and
Espionage at the same time because she's
around like to me my mother was like my
my biggest takeaway out of this episode
I thought she was excellent and yeah
that ending scene too I mean more than
just like the social commentary that it
was doing for a Star Wars fun Easter egg
you know you do get the KX unit and
reminding us of course right away of
k2so and like I don't know if that's
gonna be the Droid that you know that
specific one that um you know Cassian
will somehow convert and reprogram to
become k2so I don't think so uh I don't
I don't really know what the lower
lineage is on that I imagine we will see
that happen at some point in the show
seemed grow into allentudic but I think
that was a great tease too of part of
the Journey of what's to come because a
big part of I mean a lot of people save
your character out of Rogue one is k2so
and of course that Bond and camaraderie
between the two of them
and so it's already teasing that element
of how far he's come in that regard and
to tease the future of their
relationship eventually forming
regardless of whether or not it's that
Droid it's that immediate Association he
has with that type of droid you know I
think is a great great nuanced touch to
have
and again in like putting it in a
particularly beautiful setting and
having that cyberpunk you know just
going through this going about your time
and then to be picked up by the shore
Troopers like that was there's something
very unsettling about that and of course
leaning more weight into hey this is
like no matter what I do I'm I'm always
the enemy so my best bet it makes sense
more like you just constantly had this
reaffirm belief Cassie and Andor that no
matter what his best bet is just staying
hidden staying away you know fleeing
escaping no matter what there's no point
in fighting and that that's just another
memory that we're gonna explore that
that adds to that and then of course
everything on at the point I'm blinking
on every name right now
um forgive me guys I've been it's been
I've been up a long time uh what's the
political not Felix Barracks
um it's a dank place and then with uh
yeah that's a good way to remember it
and then seeing the memory of pharynx
and that was such a poignant moment to
note that the person who really seemed
to make a name for themselves and
established sort of a reputation was
this Clem individual who took a stand
against the clone troopers who took a
stand against the Imperial Army Imperial
Army when they were there
and for him to adopt that name when he's
going undercover
to me I'm like is that a it has to be a
specific character choice of a guy who's
so resistant towards the resistance a
guy who's resistant towards the
Rebellion yet he adopts of joining the
Rebellion yet he adopts the name of Clem
and well and in the credits he's
credited as Clem and doors so I'm
wondering oh really that yeah it's it's
right there Gary Beadle is Clem Andor so
I'm wondering how just how much more
important to him that character is
beyond that honoring of taking on yeah
the moniker of Clem like did you know is
that did he name himself for this guy or
did he help you know Marva raise him
essentially to some degree either way it
just adds more weight to the fact that
he chose that name and more way to you
know here's what happens when you take a
stand yeah end up dead so I think
there's a lot of great representations
of so I I just vehemently disagree with
casting and not being an interesting
character uh it bugs me because I feel
like this show actually does an
Exquisite job and I like an episode like
this you know where you get
like the the memory flashbacks and what
you uncover there I think just adds so
much to why this character is the way he
is and he just happens to be surrounded
by a wonderful Supporting Cast as well
who is also very very interesting like
everything with Marva was so emotional
and beautiful
and I love the ironic
the irony behind him doing this mission
on aldani
yes right
Ani ferrics where's he from again Jeff
uh
um
it's almost there it's it almost sounds
like America
and okay yeah let's make sure I got it
right so yeah you you have uh those that
scene with her was so beautiful and
heart-wrenching and the irony that he
does his mission all Donnie he wants to
use the money to get his mother he calls
her ma it's a play Imagine
and to get her and him out of there and
they could live a better life
and ironically it's the final push to
get her to be like no this planet has
stayed
dormant for too long in terms of
fighting against the empire Now's the
Time the Saldana thing was a voice is a
message sentence just like the irony
behind his actions and him not he can't
tell her
and yet it leads to this real
complicated conflict with saying bye and
or should he stay like what should he do
and then that gray area that
conversation with Bix you know like he I
like good teamwork like that where he
shows up and he's obviously looking
forward to seeing her he wants to check
up on her he's all smiles and kind of
charming this in spite of the fact he
knows what Tim did he's still there for
you know he's looking forward to her but
then she just immediately rejects him
and pushes him away and blames him for
what's happening right now because she's
grieving through this whole situation
she's not entirely wrong about you know
not at all and I think that's that the
way they complicate things with the
relationship Dynamics and the it makes
it makes it just feel that much more
personal and I think this is such an
intimate personal show
that they can do a character like the
lady blonde girl with the Empire is Miro
yeah I think her name is have a
character like her and you're you're
like I don't know why but I'm kind of
rooting for you even though Cyril in two
completely different ways but both of
them you know two of your
antagonist inclined characters you want
to see succeed somehow even though it
hurts the bottom line of the show it's
because I think they're they're
underdogs in the position that they're
in yeah and they both feel like they
have to prove something they're always
having to prove something no matter what
and they're always being hassled by
either incompetence or or people who are
just looking way far down their noses at
them people who just brush them off as
they have like almost to the point where
they have delusions of grandeur when
they don't and I think knowing that is
just adds AIDS so much to that so yeah I
think that what they did with this
particular episode was still very strong
and a very strong character-driven
episode while moving the plot in a way
that is scary like when you're checking
in on the ISB and hearing the
conversations of every thing they're
going to be enacting and what they're
going to get access to
you know it's like we know where this is
going like it's Star Wars this is like
this is all before robots so far we know
where we're headed here and we know that
the rebels are gonna be bigger and
there's gonna be more of them and then
we'll eventually defeat like we know
where it's supposed to head to
and that I think that kind of AIDS in
knowing the suspense of it all except
you're just watching like the details
play out it it feels akin to
the sense of if you've like heard of
World War II and I mean you know World
War II you know of it you know that
whole like the history of you know Nazis
in the world but then you find out like
watching the story of the details of how
it got to that point yeah of how it got
to the big war and that's where you feel
like you're watching right now yeah I
mean that's I feel like yeah that's part
of how you keep that interesting and you
alleviate the we already know what's
gonna happen is yeah you in you zero in
on the personal stories and the human
details that get wiped out in a broader
history or something like that and you
really invest in that and I think
they're really good at doing that and
showing everything from the ground level
showing like there's always a sense of
even though you know the show stays
relatively plot oriented there's always
a sense for what life is like and how it
is to live here and what people are up
against while the Empire is enforcing
all their various rules and decrees and
uh and and it feels oddly like one of
the more broad even though we haven't
been to a myriad of places yet it feels
like one of the more broad depictions
within Star Wars of so many cultures and
so many moving Parts as part of this
whole big thing and I love that part of
the argument part of the discussion this
episode and what you see people on
different emotional sides of is the fact
that yeah this is going to be ugly and
we are all going to have to compromise
what our morals say and what we are
comfortable with if we are actually
going to get our hands dirty and you
know really step up and make this happen
and not crumble and everybody is sort of
aware that this could crumble at any
moment but while we have this Flint
spark in this momentum we have to do
something with that and it's I think it
adds to the compelling nature of
cassian's character it's like yeah we
know eventually he's going to become
dedicated to this but yeah watching as
all of his plans sort of go awry in ways
that seem to all lead back to no there's
no escaping this purpose and you can't
outrun you know there's nowhere
comfortable in the Galaxy that you're
going to be able to run to where you
won't be either so eaten up by the grief
of leaving the people you love in this
[ __ ] storm
you know or yeah you know just the
general shirking of you know that moral
responsibility that eats at you and I
feel like you are absolutely right it's
like in taking on that name Clem and and
all that you know there it does probably
speak to something deep within that
wants to you know Rebel wants to you
know see some new kind of order and
goodness ushered in but it's probably
beaten down by several other prior
experiences especially like what we saw
in the flashbacks so like I feel like
they've drawn a very believable and
relatable iteration of this guy where
it's like yeah right now I can see how
and why he is Wayward as he is but I can
also see the seeds having been planted
for him to actually finally stand up and
especially with this this whole thing on
the beach is a great you know example of
that it's like he's not even doing
anything they don't even recognize him
and yet this is still an effect and if
it's you know if he just got sentenced
to six years in prison for loitering on
a beach just now things are only going
to get much much much more
you know dire and grim
well guys yeah I thought this was a
great episode I got to get to editing
this reaction right now
um but thank you so much for being here
and I I
feel like this is such an
underappreciated show but I'm glad for
those who watch it they really
appreciate it like us like you guys so
just happy to be here thank you guys
um leave a like you think your tops for
sponsoring and last but not least one is
for the pain
Kevin smart took some inspiration from
from Gregorio over here and I googled
your name I Googled Star Wars Kevin and
you know what came up Kevin
was an ewok
who stowed away on the Starship
trustworthy after it was sabotaged by
crevin the Droid partner of the pilot
Reen dude you are the perf you you are
so wonderful and kind just for being
here but now I'm gonna imagine you as
like a cuddly figure and investigating
the Starship Kevin inadvertently finds a
calm link that reveals crevin
intentionally sabotage the trustworthy
see you yourself are an uncoverer of
truths you could spark the The crucial
moments of a rebellion just yourself no
never underestimate your role in the
Galaxy even a little tiny Ewok cuddly
Cuddle Bear guy can be a hero and that's
you so uh stay smart hold fast and we'll
catch you next month thank you for being
here with us and uh hope you're enjoying
I hope you if you watch this series I
hope you are enjoying it either way I
hope you're enjoying your life much love
[Music]